الحرب في اوكرانيا اثير فيها جدلوا دور
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الروسيه بعد اتهامات
طالت الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن
بتوظيفها في الحرب ولكن ما الرابط بين
البلدين في هذا الامر منذ بدايات القرن
السابع عشر كانت اوكرانيا منضويه تحت سقف
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الروسيه واستمر ذلك
حتى عام
1992 اي بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي حيث
استعاده دول الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا
استقلالها لتحظه بذلك الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه
باستقلال تام في اداره شؤونها مع الحفاظ
على التبعيه الرسميه لموسكو لكن الاخيره
اعتبرته انشقاقا على اي حاجه مرحله
الابتعاد الثانيه كانت ما بين 2000 و2018
و 2000 و2019 حيث انشق قسم من الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه الاوكرانيه كليا عن وصفه بعد
ضمها شبه جزيره فيما وصف بانشقاق تاريخي
وبعد ثلاثه اشهر من انطلاق الحرب العام
الماضي اعلنت الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه
الاوكرانيه التابعه لروسيا قطع علاقاتها
ببطريركيه موسكو واستقلالها بشكل تام
موسكو احاله القرار الى ضغوط تعرضت لها
الكنيسه الاوكرانيه ولقطع طريق العوده
وليتوحيد قطبي الكنيسه في اوكرانيا اعلن
الرئيسكي مشروع قانون يحضر عمل اي منظمه
دينيه تابعه لروسيا لماذا يتهم الرئيس
الروسي في نادي ليفربول
بتوظيف الكنيسه في الحرب وما دورها يرى
مراقبون ان بوتن منح الكنيسه نفوذا كبيرا
على الفين وتسعه عندما اعاد ممتلكاتها
المصادره ابانا الحقبه الشيعيه ومع ضم
روسيا لشبه جزيره القرن باركه البطريركيه
الروسيه الخطوه وهو ما احرج الكنيسه فنيه
اتابعه لبطريركيه موسكو ودفعها لاعلان
استقلالها التام كما اشرنا منذ قليل في
حرب اوكرانيا يتجلى تداخل الشؤون الدينيه
بالعمليه العسكريه في ارسال موسكو عشرات
الكهنه الى جبهه القتال لدعم الجنود الروس
وفيما بدا اطفاءا لعناوين مقدسه على الحرب
عبر رئيس الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الروسيه
البطريرك عن دعمه للنزاع واكد الدعم لمن
وصفهم بالاخوه الموالينا لروسيا في شرق
اوكرانيا الذين رفضوا القيم الغربيه على
حد تعبيره في المقابل لا يغيب الاوكرانيون
عن الاشارات الدينيه في النساء مع روسيا
فالرئيس الاوكرانيا السابق بتروبريشنكا
اكد وجود رابط مباشر بين الاستقلال الديني
والسياسي حينما قال عام 2018 ان استقلال
كنيسه اوكرانيا جزءا من سيادتك المؤيده
لاوروبا والمواليه لاوكرانيا